[Music]
on this Tuesday night the growing cost
of groceries as food prices climb a new
report finds a small number of large
companies taking a bite out of the
competition Grocers are in a cozy
environment getting acclimatized with
climate change there's no magic one a
new plan to protect Canadians from
extreme weather and wildfires
damning new evidence against Donald
Trump
the tape that could take down the former
U.S president
plus looking for life in space for the
first time a NASA telescope spots a
critical compound
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin with some good news and some bad
news when it comes to the cost of living
in this country first the good there are
signs the affordability crisis is easing
Canada's inflation rate slowed to 3.4
percent last month that's the lowest
level in almost two years driven by a
big drop in gas prices but other costs
are still Rising housing for example the
amount of Interest Canadians owe on
their mortgages is climbing at a record
Pace up nearly 30 percent over last year
and many economists expect the Bank of
Canada will hike rates again next month
while gross prices compared to a year
ago are up nine percent
that growing grocery bill is being
blamed in part on a lack of competition
a highly anticipated report from
Canada's competition Bureau describes a
massive industry that's dominated by a
handful of players the months-long study
found most Canadians shop at grocery
stores owned by Loblaw sobies and Metro
those three chains pulled in a combined
profit of 3.6 billion dollars last year
the report says more competition is
needed to keep grocery prices in check
Mike drolet has our top story
[Music]
as food prices outpaced inflation last
year Canadians demanded action
but when the country's competition
Watchdog launched an investigation
Canada's grocery Giants it says weren't
exactly cooperative shocker
shocker
I mean that's the problem I mean that
that is the problem that is the big
elephant in the room how do we actually
get to a more authoritative more
forceful
Bureau the report found what most
Canadians already know that the grocery
business is controlled by the few in
fact when the competition Act was
introduced in 1986 there were eight
chains in Canada five of those were
eventually gobbled up by the big three
today with Walmart and Costco in the
picture there are five chains but while
those two newcomers operate 500 stores
the big three of Loblaw's sobies in
Metro combined have 4 850 stores when I
talk to friends and I said you know they
say oh I went to an Independent Grocer
today and they say oh who is that and
they'll say uh your Independent Grocer
and I explained to them that's a long
lost franchise it's it might say your
Independent Grocer it's not an
independent grocer it's a chain
what most Canadians likely don't know is
that the two main food wholesalers in
the country are owned by Loblaw and
sobies leaving the 6900 actual
independent grocery stores no option but
to buy their stock from their
competition if you're a sobies
wholesaler who's who comes first sobies
or your independent customers
you don't have to be a business major to
know and obviously they're going to
look after themselves first the report
made broad recommendations around
business models to improve competition
but industry insiders say they're too
vague to make an immediate difference
where the report will help they say is
in the creation of a grocery code which
is currently being written the code of
conduct will bring an end to bullying
but will also increase competition as a
result as well it will protect
Independent Grocers we we will be able
to keep small retailers with a large
chains voluntarily sign on to the code
after it's completed unlike the
independence they have a lot to lose
microlay Global News Toronto
well after more than two years of
planning and consultation the federal
government unveiled Canada's first
national adaptation strategy
while we must reduce our emissions to
keep the climate from getting worse we
must also make our communities more
resilient to the impacts of climate
change this is a whole of society plan
to reduce the risk and prepare
communities for climate impacts
Ottawa plans to spend more than one and
a half billion dollars over the next
five years to better protect against
extreme weather events such as major
storms and wildfires provinces and
municipalities are also expected to
contribute the strategy includes plans
to rethink everything from building
materials to the way we manage our
forests David Akin has the details
wildfires floods drought
extreme weather events across the
country have brought governments at all
levels together to forge a new National
adaptation strategy to help communities
prepare for the inevitable effects of
Rapid climate change
and there's no solution that that is
going to either solve mitigation or
adaptation issues overnight what we're
presenting today is a collective action
plan
Ottawa will help with funding for
example it will foot the 163 million
dollar bill for a new National flood
Hazard identification map that will be a
crucial planning tool for local
authorities but critics say more money
is needed honestly I found today's
announcement underwhelming and
disappointing
they announced their adaptation strategy
last year with 1.6 billion dollars but
we were expecting additional funding
still there are non-monetary measures in
the strategy such as overhauling the
national building codes and the highway
and bridge design code all agree on the
value of smarter land use plans and
better ways to manage forests in the
Northwest Territories for example 29
communities have completed plans to
build fire breaks soon they'll be ready
to put those plans into action that's
going to be much bigger dollars than
we've ever seen both the cost and the
amount of work to be done on adaptation
can be overwhelming the decay of
permafrost in the Northwest Territories
is a 1.3 billion dollar problem far
beyond the capacity of the territorial
government it'll be catastrophic
failures of assets potentially loss of
life and if we don't do it as a in a
proactive manner it's going to cost so
much more indeed federal government
experts say that for every dollar spent
on prevention on adaptation means saving
15 dollars in costs the cost of cleaning
up from the effects of climate change
Jeff
David Aiken and Ottawa thanks David
that National Climate adaptation plan
comes in the midst of what is now
Canada's worst Wildfire season on record
7.7 million hectares of forests have
burned in Canada this year with six
months still to go climate scientists
predict this unprecedented Wildfire
season will become The New Normal
meaning those living in and around
Canada's vast forests need to be
prepared Heather urich's West traveled
to one Alberta Community that's already
taking action
surrounded by Forest residents of Banff
Alberta spend hot summer days on edge
it's distressing I mean the minute you
start smelling smoke in the area you
just kind of your animal Instinct takes
over when Parks Canada lost control of a
prescribed burn in early May Fire King
dangerously close to the community
hundreds of people were forced from
their homes now in strong winds an ember
from a wildfire can travel up to eight
kilometers that means any property in a
forest adjacent Community is at risk of
going up in flames
so the sprinkler program is aimed at
that we can try and get water onto the
roots of these structures or in the
areas around these structures and when
those Embers come in that it's already
wet
part of a three-year pilot project the
town of Banff is offering subsidized
sprinkler kits to homeowners who sign up
for a fire smart inspection created in
Alberta back in the 90s fire smart
programs Now operate in every Province
and territory helping Property Owners
protect their homes from wildfires there
is a lot of evidence both from the U.S
and here that shows that fire smart at
the community level and at property
level can be very effective in terms of
reducing house loss and damage to
communities but in the face of
intensifying Seasons fire smart needs to
be scaled up significantly and fast
under current funding and operation
models the fire smart Alberta program
has only managed to reach 40 communities
province-wide quite often the education
and engagement falls into the hands and
responsibility of our paid on call
volunteer fire departments and so
capacity is is a tremendous barrier for
them fire smart officials agree they
need more support
so that all those who crave the
Tranquility of these Timbers are ready
for the danger ahead Heather urich's
West Global News bam
a big win for animal rights advocates in
this country the federal government is
banning all animal testing for cosmetic
products
companies will no longer be able to sell
Cosmetics that rely on animal testing
data to establish product safety and it
is now prohibited to create false or
misleading statements concerning
concerning the testing of Cosmetics on
animals
the band takes effect this December by
amending the Food and Drug Act the move
brings Canada in line with 43 other
countries that have already imposed
similar measures including the UK
Australia and the EU
evidence has emerged in the U.S federal
case against Donald Trump accused of
keeping and mishandling classified
documents despite Trump's previous
denials a leaked audio recording now
appears to capture a moment when the
former president was holding a secret
document
isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confidential
there's a secret information
in the 2021 recording obtained by CNN
Trump allegedly discusses the
confidential files with his staffers as
well as a writer and publisher at one
point the conversation sounds like he's
showing them a Secret Pentagon document
containing a plan of attack against Iran
I think the evidence could be used
against the former president to show
both that he was careless with secret
classified information uh it could be
shown to illustrate or to prove his
knowledge that this information remained
classified and it could not be shared
publicly
Trump was federally indicted earlier
this month on 37 counts relating to the
documents he's pleaded not guilty to all
charges if convicted he could face years
in prison
in Ukraine at least two people were
killed when Russian missiles pounded a
city on the Eastern Front Line
22 others were hurt including a child
there are concerns more people are
pinned under that debris the attack
targeted a restaurant and a busy
shopping area in the city center a major
rescue operation is now underway the
president of Belarus is claiming the
leader of the mercenary Wagner group has
arrived in his country Alexander
lukashenka a loyal Ally of Russian
President Putin offered Refuge to evgeny
pagosian after brokering a deal to stop
Saturday's Russian Rebellion it's
unclear what will happen to pagosian
after he spearheaded one of the greatest
challenges to Putin's grip on power as
Jackson prosco reports Putin is
reasserting his authority
undoubtedly weakened by the failed
Mutiny Vladimir Putin tried to project
strength from the steps of the Kremlin
you saved our motherland from the
turmoil he told a crowd of his security
forces in fact you stopped a civil war
he said
the man who orchestrated the armed
Rebellion yevgeny pregosian has been
banished to Belarus where he may well
avoid formal prosecution
his Wagner mercenary Fighters have been
given a choice join the Russian army or
join their leader in Exile they're
supposed to turn in their weapons along
the way
in men's Bella Russian leader Alexander
lukashenka claimed to have brokered the
deal in a nationally televised address
he offered rare criticism of Putin's
response to the Insurrection
if Russia Falls we will be buried under
the wreckage he warned that's really
telling that Vladimir Putin not only
seemed paralyzed for the first about 15
hours of this Mutiny or coup but that
also didn't play a critical role in
resolving it himself yet if pagosian's
goal was to shake up Russia's military
command over the faltering war in
Ukraine he seems to have failed
Russia's defense minister Sergey shoigu
was still apparently in his job Tuesday
despite calls for his ouster my strong
sense is that we're really only seeing
the First Act of this process whether
the stage is Moscow and New threats to
Putin's leadership
or Ukraine is as yet unknown Russian
turmoil could be the opening Kiev has
been looking for as it mounts its
counter-offensive the Kremlin insists it
will not be deterred from its goals even
as cracks appear in its armor
Jackson crosco Global News Washington
and new data from the United Nations is
revealing the scale of Russia's
brutality in Ukraine the U.N monitoring
Mission interviewed more than 1100
people investigators found more than 900
cases of civilians being arbitrarily
detained including children and seniors
the vast majority of those prisoners
said they were tortured and in some
cases sexually abused the U.N also
documented the execution of at least 77
civilians in captivity on the other side
the report found Ukraine had arbitrarily
detained at least 75 people with more
than half reporting torture or
mistreatment
torontonians have chosen their next
mayor coming up Olivia Chow's remarkable
comeback and historic victory
plus the disastrous Deja Vu at this
apartment complex
thank you to the people of Toronto for
the trust you've placed in me and the
Mandate for change as your new mayor
Olivia Chow will be the next mayor of
Canada's largest city her victory speech
focused on affordability vowing to bring
change to a city she says has endured a
decade of neglect Chao also vowed to
work with Ontario's conservative Premier
Doug Ford who openly endorsed and
supported another candidate
it's a political comeback of sorts for
the former NDP MP she ran unsuccessfully
for that job a decade ago ciao is now
the first woman of color to lead the
city and her win represents an end to
more than a decade of center-right
leadership Eric Sorensen now on the
challenges facing Toronto's next mayor
answering a question in Cantonese has to
be a first the first Chinese Canadian
mayor in Canada's largest city a
remarkable Resurrection for Olivia Chao
after leaving politics almost 10 years
ago when she lost the mayor's race and
following the death of her husband NDP
leader Jack Layton
[Applause]
I'm back for herb and for progressives
at Toronto City Hall promising
affordable housing better and safer
public transit and even higher taxes to
pay for it have sent a message today
they want to get things done a message
of more investment less austerity says
this professor Toronto is an amazing
City but it's been decaying and if we're
not willing to raise the revenue that we
need to support the city it's going to
continue to Decay Olivia Chao comes to
Toronto City Hall with a clear victory
over Anna Bilal who made it close in
part with an endorsement from previous
Mayor John Tory but the other main
Challenger former police chief Mark
Saunders wound up with barely eight
percent after Premier Doug Ford gave him
a late endorsement is that a rejection
of you well I I knew you were going to
ask me this one the result was awkward
for Ontario's Premier who said this just
a few days ago if Olivia child gets in
it'll be unmitigated disaster a
different tone now during the election
you throw some mud back and forth but
I'll tell you one thing people uh people
expect us to work together and that's
exactly what we're going to do the new
mayor agrees there's common ground on
issues like housing I can absolutely
work with Premier deaf Ford but sharp
differences exist over private
investment at Ontario Place and
addressing the city's billion dollar
deficit you're going to get your fiscal
house in order ciao wants to partner
with the province and Ottawa because at
the end of the day a healthy and livable
City of Toronto needs a strong Canada
Toronto's last Progressive mayor says
Chao can Marshall's support from other
Mayors to bring change but even more
historic electing an immigrant woman
it's not just that she's Progressive I
think she's symbolic of what Toronto is
today we're a diverse welcoming City
where newcomers can succeed and I think
that's a very good thing the premier is
giving new powers to Ontario Mayors to
override the majority on Council but
Chao says she won't take them I believe
in democracy you'll stick with the old
way one person one vote Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
a discovery that's out of this world
still ahead with the James Webb
Telescope spotted in space
[Music]
a large fire broke out at an apartment
building in the United Arab Emirates
early this morning a tower of flames
shooting up the side of the 36-story
residential high-rise no injuries were
reported a large fire tore through two
towers in that same complex in 2016.
devastating flash floods and landslides
struck Southern China today leaving at
least four people dead and several
others missing the slides forced more
than 900 people to flee their homes
officials say hundreds of Rescuers are
taking part in the search for at least
three people who are still missing
astronomers have detected a critical new
carbon compound in space for the first
time the James Webb Telescope traced it
to a young star system about 1300 light
years away the compound AIDS the
formation of more complex carbon-based
molecules that are the foundation of all
known forms of life the discovery could
help scientists understand how life
developed on Earth and how it could
possibly develop in other places
and that is global national for this
Tuesday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight
your Canada is this old grain elevator
in Fanny's towel Manitoba thanks for
watching Eric Sorensen will be at the
anchor desk with you tomorrow and I'll
see you again on Thursday have a great
night
[Music]
thank you